[Music]
what's an app that a bunch of people are
using that's kind of being somewhat
respectful of this is there anything
that you think is kind of doing it right
there's all sorts of different examples
I mean I try not to have time well-spent
represent like the barbers organic food
store like you know organic apps but
right you know like things like calendly
for example helps people you know when
you schedule a meeting you normally send
six emails back and forth and now that
time doesn't work and right people
forget to ask which day they'd like to
me they just say yeah I'd like to meet
write of stuff so calendly let someone
else schedule [ __ ] time on your
calendar in the kind of a deliberate way
you pay for it and it saves people time
and they spend more time living in less
time scheduling and they charge for it
that's one example of a time well-spent
thing things like flex take the blue
light out of your screen when you add
about 15 minutes of quality sleep per
night for per person who uses it yeah
you have flex and so like I did well I
have one of them installed that does
dark and I don't know if it's flux but
something does not in my screen and yet
evening yet right and so I do that is
like that's adding 15 minutes of quality
sleep to your life so you know there's a
delivered benefit phenomenologically in
your life because of using that thing
yeah you know there's a thing called one
second every day that instead of posting
to social media in this sort of
open-ended way you just like capture one
second of your life and then at the end
of a year it just like compiled all that
together into this one big memory reel
so you can think of that as reorganizing
all these little blocks of time you
might spend capturing selfies in your
life and your day and looking through
them all the time to suddenly having
just one big flock at the end for you
see them
yeah sort of there's just reorganizing
these little blocks of time into
something that adds up that's better
how much for the amount that you care
about this is a sort of split between
happiness and productivity because a lot
of what you described there was like
productivity yeah I did and but there
there is an ancillary happiness because
totally overboard
I mean you are this is about in
productivity to see a life yeah this is
about like where what is time will spend
for us in our lives like meaning it's
for democracy like what is the part of
your life that's dedicated to being
informed or to having conversations yeah
I can imagine
a hundred thousands of
disempowering ways if I could like
puppeteer your life I can actually like
really disempowering ways for you to be
put into situations with someone else
and have like a tack dog style
conversations I know it's the whole
point of what you're trying to do right
all right and then these hour chunk some
very good Twitter's a whole other
situation that's an example of me so the
odd cats are like these different blocks
of time that that that might enable
forms of discourse that just wouldn't
happen so I'm logically on a screen I
mean I just gave it a TED talk about
those you know when you when you go to
Facebook and you post something
controversial the menu being provided by
Facebook is which key do you want to
type right versus maybe host to dinner
tomorrow night and people go to RSVP
right there and that's scheduling a
block of time later which would be more
empowering for having a controversial a
conversation about something
controversial yeah so you can think of
that as none about productivity
it's not about happiness but it's about
what are the values for that like life
activity and that life activity is being
able to talk about something
controversial in an empowering ways
probably better do that face to face
right you know it's something like this
yeah and on a screen and yet everyone's
doing it on a screen and that's one of
the things when I have talked about this
I see this all the time people email me
all the time you know I posted something
that I thought was pretty basic or
centrist on Facebook and now my brother
won't talk to me my Grandin's angry at
me and all these things so these things
were I'd like to think that the original
reason most of these things were were
made was to connect us and yet I think
we've turned a corner now where yes
there's a lot of good there we know this
can you know these things can create
revolutions and other parts we all know
that but I do think we're starting to
turn a corner into where the social
interactions are becoming more
destructive than positive I I don't know
if I don't know if it's 50/50 or maybe
it's not quite more than well because
it's so nuanced and complex it leaves
people throwing up their hands and
saying like well social media seems to
be ruining democracy but I get all these
benefits from it it's complicated to
let's just like assume that it's never
going to change and we're stuck with
what we have yeah first is asking in a
more critical way when are the kinds of
let's say having rich meaningful open
minded conversations about controversial
topics when is that happening on social
media I mean
right did this thing with Sam Harris
someone pointed us to this reddit thread
there's a reddit thread channel called
um
I think changed my mind or something
like that or changed my mind and that
has a whole like a whole channel
dedicated to people's mind being open
and changed and having conversations in
a way that appears to be working but if
you were to rate you know Facebook
threads for that like it doesn't turn
out so well right but then knowing that
wouldn't wouldn't we want to diagnose
what specifically goes wrong in the feed
to have conversations about
controversial topics and then Facebook
if it had like a team of nonviolent
communicators and political theorists
and you know constitutional scholars
asking like what are like the best
conversations that are best for people
they can imagine steering people towards
a totally different block of time which
might be again that post dinner you know
the host dinner buttons right underneath
that article and you could just say
let's talk about it yeah person would
the ultimate irony be though that this
what we're doing right this second two
feet away from each other really is the
only way to truly do it in like a
completely holistic way because even
when I do these interviews on skype so
it's someone I like and respect and know
about and engage with there is simply a
difference in in the interaction than
there is when you're right sitting right
next to somebody so there's that there
is a difference in any mediated versus
non mediated forms of communication but
I think there's also something to say
for people's capacity to do it I think
that's what you and Sam and Eric I know
Weinstein as well you know talk about it
is like people have to have the ability
to say what would convince me otherwise
as much as I am convinced I would be so
frustrated if someone's speaking from a
perspective that's just so obviously
wrong to be able to do that seal Manning
move you know got like well what's the
best possible argument for your position
and that's something that someone would
have to be willing to do so even
face-to-face doesn't automatically
enable someone with this capacity to
zoom in right but that would be
something you might want to build into
mediated forms of communication I'm
doing imagine next to the Facebook
button next to commented like what's the
best possible version of what they're
saying yeah as your first response I
mean just imagine that would like tweak
little bits of conversations that are
happening a billion times a day yeah so
I think we need some more of that and
then of course this is exactly what
you're working on
kind of traction do you feel like you're
getting sort of a just generally
speaking like you know you've had a
couple nice as you said the TED talk and
going on Sam's podcast so there's
obviously some some movement here but
then also related to the to the
companies themselves well I think the
hard part first is getting to the point
where we could admit that those are
problems I think there's a lot of times
in history when there was a problem but
we didn't have an economic transition
from it yet and until there was an
economic transition from say advertising
we can't admit that there is problems of
advertising so what I found is this is
resonating like crazy I think the world
feels like they're being gas lit and the
technology companies are not saying you
know like that they are shaping our
attention and making these choices for
us not that they're responsible or
they're they're evil or they're
manipulative that's not what it's about
but just that the race for attention is
kind of driving us crazy
yeah it's driving us crazy individually
but our minds are just polluted and then
you know democratically the
conversations were at like just to admit
that that is in fact happening so that
response from from the from culture at
large it is very very positive I just
did 60 minutes with Anderson Cooper
talking about the stuff and the response
has been incredible that's one step I
think there's also a recognition slowly
within companies that this is really a
problem and part of their ability to see
that the problem is that people need to
be speaking up and saying yeah this is
really happening to me and they have to
be emailing their friends at tech
companies saying like yeah this is
really happening I don't think there's a
way for them to to transition yet
because they have to be able to say this
is how would work otherwise differently
right people aren't even thinking that
way because the only way to think right
now is what's going to get more people
detention yeah I think it's not no one's
ever thought like what would we just be
best for days right like just like the
best screen for him right now
right imagine I have no other interest
it's like oh you're just lonely let me
like help you get out with your friends
right I can totally help you that I have
all day I know exactly who else is
lonely right now yeah but I I've never
been in a task where I'm just focused on
like what's best for people yeah so
that's part of what I'm trying to teach
with time well-spent it there's a
different way to design stuff that is a
totally different discipline
I've been asking what's the time line
looks like best for this person at this
moment whether it's a conversation they
want to have or they're lonely on a
Tuesday night or whatever not to go too
depressing with this but in a weird way
aren't you battling something that that
can't be won at some level like whether
the technology will just keep going I
guess even if a lot of people get on
board with this hopefully people watch
this and go yeah maybe I need a little
less screen time or I need to be a
little more aware or whatever it is but
that the technology is just going to
keep coming and even if you eventually
got Google to change a few things and
you got Twitter to change the mentions
and a few things that just the onslaught
of this stuff there's so much of it now
yeah there are obviously people with bad
intentions there are people with good
intentions that still accidentally do
bad things all that stuff Alice's that
it's like you're trying to take a
principled position sort of against
technology as it's like as like the wave
of Technology just hits us endlessly you
know what's interesting is at the end of
the day the people who make it are all
human beings like and so back to
persuasion we're all just people who are
persuaded by different things I think
that as people see the cost of this on
their own children no one wants to live
in this world that we're creating so
like there's just no human being who's
excited to live in a world where the
screens are optimized to make it hard to
have conversations about democracy not
intentionally but unintentionally no one
wants to live in a world where kids with
our own kids get hooked to doing
something that developmentally stuns
them no sense them no one wants that
yeah I think just say the human
connection like I mean that's the
broader part here they're just crushing
the the actual human connect yeah yeah
and just but I mean in terms of this
David and Goliath thing it's like the
more that we tap into a relationship of
my actions designing the screen this way
are causing this specific results in
society for this tiny little thing and I
didn't intend to do it we're not blaming
you for doing it but just to see that
there is a link that if I designing the
choice menu this way I'm creating that
outcome and that I can see what if I
design it this other way it would create
a positive outcome
people have to see that that is even
possible - right now we're so all
everyone is so trapped in like this will
beYOU of like maximizing attention and
engagement that they can't even imagine
what the other thing would be like right
they're trying to maximize attention and
yet we're crushing attention through
that which is which is fascinating have
you ever thought that maybe the next
step with all of this would be that you
would have to be part of building a new
device altogether yeah I mean so we the
unfortunate truth is that like if you
think of this is there's a city that
won't like a billion people are like
jacked into like the matrix yeah very
matrix theme around all this that we're
the batteries or the work for these kind
of anything yeah yeah yeah and again you
know no evil thing just that's the
business model so we're all batteries
and the system that has colonized our
own mind I think something very deep in
even deeper than that identity in any
way now we can go there too yeah and I
think very very perverted right does
it's really deeper into the brain stem
as identity deeper in the brain stem is
it's not just behavior it's not just
feeling a little more more distracted
but but let's pause there for a second I
think there's something interesting
there like yeah I even see like I'm
pretty tolerant of trolls online right
they annoy they can annoy the hell out
of me when I see that they derail a
conversation that I think is really
interesting but to me it's like this is
a lot of it sucks if you're just
anonymously creating 80 accounts just
fighting with everybody all that but
like the troll culture is something that
I do understand it's people just having
fun and annoying people or whatever it's
just more than anything else it just
seems like it's part of being human so
that's just the more we peer into this
thing we're sort of just peering into
ourselves right we're pairing into
ourselves but the question is are there
like little viral coefficients or
amplifiers and up regulators and down
regulators and so you can imagine a
Facebook version of Facebook newsfeed
that knows who the trolls are and then
hits a big up regulator just like dial
them way up and so now you're looking at
the troll feet right it's just like the
maximum trolling every story that gets
posted is the first comment to someone
being like just totally trolling you
yeah and just and just noticing what
phenomenological experience with that
created people versus another version of
Facebook where it does down regulates
all of those trolls and there's just
like note folds anywhere you go they
actually could create both of those
feeds right but we have to have a
conversation about
the daleney we need a troll dial
basically and you can up it sometimes if
you want to have that you can down it
sometimes that's another question is
like at the end of the day I could give
a user like a million dials yeah and and
at some point there's a sort of
necessary paternalism of the Facebook
designers saying look whether we want to
or not we're bumping our elbows into
people either having a lot of trolls or
like a less troll so we have to decide
but right now it's actually all
unconscious so the Facebook newsfeed for
example and this is a little hole filter
bubble thing it learns what you click on
that confirms your worldview and without
even knowing it it sort of persuades you
more and more with your worldview
because if they had a choice between the
confirm your worldview feed and the the
world is way more complicated and
reference than what you think it is feed
like no one would spend time on the
world complicated and difficult feat
like people would get burned out and say
I'm not going in space without more I
probably would but I figured but it
would require values you have to value
that because it would actually require
patience
it would require dealing with complexity
reading like eating word choices that
are unfamiliar to you like there's a
whole bunch of stuff that would be
harder without living in our world so I
did a video a couple weeks ago on how I
think internet culture is leaking into
real culture and I think you've sort of
hit this in the political thing where
now we cater a news feed to ourselves
our own opinions are constantly
reinforced we then defriend people who
don't back us on those things everyone
else is evil and all that stuff and now
we think we see this now leaking out
into politics you know there's a certain
way that politicians talk now obviously
this has a lot to do with Trump how they
all everything this control thing that
was just on our phones in our laptops is
now leaking out to society do you see
that as like a new piece of this well I
think I'm you know we've we've always
been infected by things like consumerism
is that we our desires actually became
the desires of advertisers so like we're
just like walking around pursuing
lifestyles and images we saw on
television curling up and I think you
know that's that's always a carryover
from you know lots of mediated
experiences getting kind of you know
washing things and then suddenly leaving
walking out the door and not being in
front of a television and still wanting
all these things that we didn't want so
I think it's a necessary byproduct we
have to see the humanity is so
persuadable
than to ask what would be the persuasive
world you want to live in because right
now the politically persuasive world is
persuading us to understand each other
less to want to move away from anybody
we don't understand yeah and actually
physically do you like just spatially
they're further away if you wanted to
have a conversation with someone to
disagree with you probably have to drive
yeah well right we could probably find
somebody over probably agree I think we
could find somebody what are some of
your habits as you become aware of this
stuff how much did it change I suspect
yeah years ago when you were at Google
and you were working on this stuff you
were probably on this thing
well the we're close to 24 hours a day
the worst part is because I know that
all these techniques constantly a.m.
when I when I find myself falling into a
trap yeah like I even got you yeah
that's the thing about persuasion like
this so I've studied from all of these
different disciplines there's a lab
actually at Stanford called the
persuasive technology lab and I learned
all these techniques and what I found is
everybody in the field of persuasion
whether it's like these dark marketing
conferences or these persuasion experts
or the behavioral economist like Daniel
Kahneman they'll say that even though
these are like the world experts on what
pushes our buttons you're still human
right like you can't escape it like I
mean this is just how it you work right
this is the magic insight to that you
know sleight of hand magic works on
every single mind no matter how smart
you are no matter what language you
speak no matter what culture you come
from like it's a feature of how your
mind works yeah the whole stuff but but
up like just it happens to you so so in
terms of how I you know live this stuff
it's I'm just more aware of all the
stuff as it's doing stuff to me what I
then try to do is sort of meta design
the environment so that there's fewer of
the things that persuade me the way they
don't like so that's like turning off
notifications yeah launching apps by
typing which forces you to make a
conscious choice as much as possible
going through direct doorways so for
example G's an iPhone I do okay so when
you open an iPhone you want to write
yourself an email you probably like like
scroll over to the app and then open it
right and then you see the long list a
new email and you wait a couple seconds
you want to see if anything came in
right and then you're probably going to
hit the new you know button but maybe
some new email just came in and now you
- thinking about something else and you
forget yeah what you were doing what you
can do instead is type from the very
beginning the screen swipe down type ma
for mail to show up and then alright and
then hold on to doting go into it hold
on to like hard press into it if you
have a new iPhone hard press into it it
shows you a submenu where you can say
new message and so when you open up mail
you're going like direct pathway so
there's just no detours along the path
between like my mind wanting to do
something and then getting to do it yeah
you can imagine instead of that being on
your shoulders to adopt that habit like
Apple and Google could make that build
into how all that stuff works yeah which
if they really wanted to help us be
functional they would do that and
actually in certain ways more efficient
because a lot of times you have an
important email to send and and then
right you've gone off on that detour now
you're looking at six other things and I
can't even remember - and it's not like
companies are profiting from that right
I mean it's important to say like just
for the email for example no Google or
Apple is making money when you check
email and nothing there right so it's
not like they're profiting it was not
something that they're going to lose
money so this is just a matter of
whether or not they take responsibility
that there is a design solution and they
could fix it you know if you really
understand how people work it's like
we're so predictable like at any given
moment in time we're kind of picking
from an invisible menu of things that
occur to us to be doing and like right
now if you just snap your fingers
wherever you are listening to this or
watching this like there's a certain
menu that's available to you about what
you're doing probably just going to keep
continue listening or watching but if
there is ever like a moment of just
boredom or if we just stop talking for
the next 15 seconds yeah like for a
moment people would probably be like I
wonder if I should check because because
your phone puts a new choice on life's
menu at any single moment that's going
to taste sweeter than reality like it
outcompetes being there with yourself on
a toilet like yeah like just be there
and be uncomfortable and just be have
nothing to do but that is not that's
that's going to be totally out competed
there's a sweeter option on the menu now
to then catch up on something you could
be more productive you could be
stimulated you could tweet you could
learn something I mean you even
productive positive things not just
amusing right so we would have to be
willing to give up something if we were
going to check our phone in that moment
that you'd have to be able to say yeah I
could like get back to that last text
message and you be if you didn't respond
you'd be giving up simply yeah and
that's that's what we'd have to do that
people have to see that that's the trade
that they would be making so when I
first heard you on Sam's podcast a
couple weeks ago you know his his last
book was it was basically about mindful
meditation and waking up wake up a you
know inner peace without religion in his
case but for our purposes whether it's a
religion or meditation or whatever it is
are we just losing that you know like
when you're describing that to me it's
like I always think it's funny like if
you're meeting a friend somewhere and
you have to stand on a corner for one
minute yeah you will always look at your
phone the whole time I will try not to
now right
but like the default is you're standing
somewhere and instead of even if you're
in a town you've never been to yep
looking at different people looking at
the restaurants you just go to this
thing and I think it's important to ask
to be fair to the the techno optimists
here like which is actually best for you
like in that moment there's sort of you
and then there's this like invisible
block of time which is what you do for
the next 10 seconds like if we're just
asking with what's best for Dave in that
one moment would it be for you to look
up and just be people watching or would
it be to like get back to that that last
other two text messages that you wanted
to get back to right and it's not clear
that like looking up and just people
watching is like automatically better
right just to play the kind of not to
play it fall into the naturalistic
fallacy that other things are just
better before when we were just bored
all the time right and I don't buy back
but I think for someone like me that in
this stuff all the time I cherish you
need that exactly yeah and then knowing
that because I do also know something
about you know when people spend just a
lot of time on a screen one of the
things with time well-spent that we're
doing is we have these ratings of given
how much time you spent per app in
general on the screen how much screen
time per app is like a happy amount and
which is like the unhappy amount right
we find is the unhappy amount is about
2.4 times the happy amount mean like if
you think it's like 26 minutes on
Facebook is like okay but if you're on
there for 60 minutes everyone
unilaterally says like this is like not
good perfect so it's telling us
something about like you know if your
phone asked you what time will spent for
you using me like you know and if just
in your breaks knowing that your
and a person uses it all the time it
would maybe help you give some feedback
before you better check it in that
street corner and make it easier for you
to not do that yeah what else can we do
well in our remaining time here let's
only work on the positives what what
else can we do to give people more time
agency yeah and just control over this
so for the people that are out there
that are watching this right now that
have just completely lost control yeah
that's the main group we got to get to
first yeah yeah I mean so one of the
things is on the time well-spent website
we have some tips there's this whole
take control section and not so I have
no book here I'm not consulting I'm not
selling I can just be greater I just
were trying to help people there's some
things there I mean I think a few things
you can do is one there's a difference
between notifications from machines and
notifications from people yeah most
things that your phone buzzes for even
though it seems like it's from a person
actually from the machine like your
friend just posted on Facebook that's
from a machine it's not from the person
yeah it's about a person but actually
being invented by a growth hacker
someone whose job is to build engagement
as much as possible for Twitter or
something to find these new seductive
things to throw at you and pull you in
what we should do is turn off all those
notifications and just have it when a
person wants your attention because that
means if your phone buzzes you know for
sure that there's something worth maybe
responding to right so in your ideal
world the company would listen to
someone like you and just not even put
that as the automatic default when you
download that right now so I handed that
because of the business model of
advertising right there we losing
attention market share because someone
else is going to swoop in and grab it if
they they leave it on the table right so
your solution to your really you're
really that this point is trying to
empower the people this example is just
people know the first is just how do we
have some band-aids to deficits to
better our skirt situation so one is
turning off notifications another one is
having finding these direct pathways
like there are simple examples when you
set your alarm you know if we're going
to bed you can unlock your phone and go
into it and find the alarm clock and do
the whole thing if you just swipe up
there's a nighttime clock right there
and that just that just means that you
don't have to go in all the time so the
more you're like you keep this locked
keeping yourself locked out as much as
possible learning to use Siri when
you're locked learning to these kinds of
things are helpful mm-hmm another one is
typing the name of the app
and then another one is setting a custom
vibration for text messages so like
right now if I get a text message from a
person that's through iMessage on my
phone I actually have a custom vibration
of like three quick buzzes so that you
know if you're at your phone just
buzzing once it could be like your you
know house is on fire or it might be
like you know someone posted on Facebook
right and because you don't know you put
you in this loop we have to check all
the time and if you have clarity so that
your phone buzzes in a very specific way
with three quick buzzes which you can
set up then you don't follow to that fat
trap yeah do you think that if people
don't get on board a lot of the stuffs
that you're talking about that we're
going to have like a massive
anti-technology movement because I think
you see little bit to this you know we
see like little camps where people are
shutting down I told you about me
shutting down occasionally but but do it
better
yeah it's why I've been trying twice a
year I did it last time I did it was
basically Christmas week and and
actually the first time I did it which i
think was about a year ago I got back
and something that I had taped on the
show right before I had this interview
with the actor Stephen Fry and it caused
like a real outrage thing and it was on
the cover of a lot of things in the UK
and I didn't hear about it for ten days
and I had my agent and him and his
people contact me in front but then I
got back on and then I was just slammed
like I finally had a little like sense
of decency or clarity and then second
you get back on your I get in the over
and then boom bang it's all that
explodes in your face yeah so but that
being said I'm glad that I did it and I
want to continue doing it what do you
think about like a real anti-technology
movement as I do sense that there's
going to be at least some some growth
there I I think the key thing here is
not to make it a black-and-white issue
that when we say like oh we should just
like look up from our screens and like
deal with a really discomfort of being
human in the 21st century and all the
stuff that's going on now I mean that's
unrealistic but I do think so what one
the whole point of time well-spent is we
need to design Renaissance we need to be
able to ask like what is the life what
is the sort of you guy monic you know
human flourishing like amount of
relationships we want to be having like
do we want to be texting back and forth
per day when we want to go to sleep what
are the you know how old is our
short-term memory what are these like
finite limits of
being alive as a human and having your
phone defend and honor each of those
boundaries like it should be on your
team given the sort of dimensions of
what a human life is as opposed to just
saying like there are no boundaries are
just going to blow past every very try
to put up because like every screen is
going to autoplay the video into your
head or something right so we really do
need a design Renaissance I think that
in terms of where this is going I think
the first step is people to see that the
current design patterns are not on your
team like I think people should feel a
little bit of disgust in an outrage
rightfully so because their minds are
being hijacked and that the stuff isn't
an accident and it's a result of good
well-intentioned people who are simply
having to fall into this race to the
bottom to grab attention and then we can
all just see that we're being
manipulated and it doesn't feel good and
it's not helping democracy and it's not
helping like our inner lives and I think
that's the sort of like movement that
needs to happen that's the sort of anti
technology or new technology limit of a
sort of humane technology movement yeah
are you getting any pushback from the
powers that be right because it's sort
of like you're doing a little bit of a
you know showing them you know yeah yeah
I mean I I think that all I'm doing is
saying things that are just factually
true I mean nothing I've said is you can
disagree with any of the facts I think
people have have arguments on the shelf
to pull out to say well I think net
positive the existing Facebook newsfeed
is like a good thing for Humanity right
there's all these little like one-liners
that you can kind of throw at this right
but at the end of the day you could ask
couldn't we have a phone in our pocket
that just works a lot better for like a
humans yeah and we could it could we
have a newsfeed it's like a lot better
for democracy and we could we have a
newsfeed that's a lot better for like
not promoting cyberbullying and we could
these just would take very deliberate
conscious efforts that to design it
differently right so it sort of it
sounds counter to business but
ironically everything that you're
presenting is a business opportunity
actually it could be a business
opportunity if people saw that they were
being sold garbage right hell yeah
they're kind of like the design patterns
just are about you know manipulating as
much as possible and that's why I use
the metaphor of the organic food
movement people had to first you know
until like 1970 like you eating food off
the shelf you have no idea that there's
a difference between stuff that has
whatever some bad pet
besides we figure out later is like
really bad for us mm-hmm so first step
is like oh there's some stuff that's not
good for us and we don't want that some
people have to see that they
unconsciously or without consent have
been you know stuffed full of this stuff
it's not really good for us and if
there's a career way in which it's not
good for us cuz right now people have
had like missing language describe like
I know something's not right that I
don't know what it is and I'm hoping
that we're going out there people see
that the thing that's not right is this
race for attention that's just going low
on the brainstem and that thing that's
not right yeah so we would all want this
other better thing so are you getting
pushback from the powers that be um so
far I think I think they're feeling the
pressure more and more from things like
60 minutes yeah that was the first time
that something like 13 million people
you know tuned in but I'm really not
trying to be out there bombastic and
accusing anybody I'm not implying you
are but just the nature of anything is
that you're saying there's something
wrong there's everything wrong here yeah
but at the end of the day you know the
other thing same thing is I'm friends
with a lot of them I mean I'm from the
industry I had a guy company we you know
we're talent acquired by Google my
friends started Instagram I these are
all good people many of them my friends
I'm just pointing on an honest problem
with what's the race for attention costs
us and democracy yeah if you were a
betting man ten years have we done some
of this stuff I mean have we we have to
like I'd literally don't see us
surviving as a species if we don't solve
the problem so I'm kind of on board that
but what does that really mean to you
like if we don't where where does this
really take us I mean I think you know I
said this recently like I think that the
the most important problems in the world
require people being able to coordinate
and use their attention like the way
they want to like if you cannot control
where your mind goes you you can't build
like family relationships don't work
development of human beings from
children up to adulthood doesn't work if
people people's relationships are really
shallow or they're distracted all the
time that's just like an existential
threat
it's just how anyone in any culture any
language is going to be affected by this
yeah
things like you know global problems
like climate change or other things
require the ability to coordinate our
attention so you know democracy requires
agreement and conversation and debate
and the ability to talk about things
that are really hard to talk about it's
talk about radioactive topics and to do
it an open-minded way if you can't get
to the point we have that conversation
the only other alternative is violence
so we either get there or we have
violence or we do some mixture model of
the both and we hopefully realize that
we need this better system at the other
end yeah I gotta say I mean I knew I was
going to enjoy this conversation as I
said to you when you walked in but like
it does people ask me why why do I do
this show the way I do it and it has so
much to do with exactly what exactly I
think about well that's why I wanted to
come on because because I you know and
this is something I share with Eric
Weinstein you came word before is we all
see that that some of the most important
things in the world are these
controversial things we have people talk
about something that more to talk about
and anyway I didn't interrupt yep that's
plaits no but that that's the funny
thing is that like I only do it this way
because I wanted someone to do it and
that was like why isn't anyone doing
this I guess I'll do it I didn't know if
it was going to work or not right but in
a way that's the exact same premise that
you're going off of here is like
somebody needs to just start doing this
so you're just talking about it and
hopefully some of these companies come
around right and start the pushback yeah
and see that it's possible that like you
know that organize a dinner button could
show up in a Facebook newsfeed and what
difference would that make in like
little choices that people would make in
their lives it's supposed to you know
debating that thing on the screen versus
showing on on Tuesday and like having a
conversation that's more like this but
in a distributed way yeah is the
ultimate irony of all this is that you
have to do this digitally you have to do
this through a site again and we have to
do this on YouTube and I have to tweet
this interview out late early Instagram
a picture of us you know all of that
stuff but you know it's like with time
well-spent as a movement and nonprofits
have been and you know we try not to
maximize like oh where we hit like a
million people today or writing like
that but you know it matters and I think
yes it you have to have it matter to you
not in the way where you want to
maximize it you know it matters to you
that the message getting out there and
it's resonating and then what's
interesting I think is if you speak
really truthfully and and the message
comes across like the independent
magnitude of like the thing that
offering something different just
automatically starts to spread yeah well
I mean I think it's cool and it's honest
which i think is something that's so
lacking and it makes sense why you know
getting people off of some of this stuff
so we can start having real
conversations again is good it's one of
the reasons why people sometimes say
well why don't you do shows five days a
week and it's like well because I also
know you've got a life to live right oh
really like you give me two hours we
only post two interviews a week you give
me two hours of your time right a week
right give you twenty minutes of your
time that's pretty good right and so
that's what I think we need more so I
will help you somehow you want some help
yeah I hope this offers some help but
I'd love to figure out some other ways
that yeah yeah yeah Barton is totally I
mean we're actually in the early
processes of sort of formalizing you
know the strategy for how we're going to
do this I recently met some really good
powerful folks who are going to help um
you know we used to be a lot of there's
a lot of people I would say in the
industry who used to play this game and
they understand how it works I mean they
understand they made a lot of money from
it at some point and now they're like I
see this I mean a lot of the election it
was like run by outraged news feeds and
fake sensationalism if not fake news and
advertising where you can pay to reach a
susceptible audience which is a real
true thing forget Cambridge analytic if
I pay Facebook I can target that
specific pool of people with a lie like
all I have to do is pay and there's no
way Facebook can regulate that because
whoever pays them the most gets to walk
in the door they had 100 Elian times a
second it doesn't have a way of saying
what I look at your intentions in your
eyes squinting in real ways personally
on it right right so so anyway I think
people are slowly seeing at a human
level what it's costing all of us and
that they they want to help and I'd love
to talk to you about ways we could you
know get more help I mean if this is
really one of those things that have to
be you know out there for everybody and
a big way
all right great well you guys obviously
should check out time well-spent and
check out Tristan's website which is
Tristan Paris back if you know what you
always say Tristana writer's done it
took I 20 time today Tristan it's not
Tristan is Prasad Kristen Harris Dada
[Music]
you
[Music]